gives me great pleasure to announce
agreement and principal on the mff
midterm review revision for 2014-2020
the agreement reinforces EU support for
tackling the migration crisis
strengthening security and boosting
growth and creating jobs the concept
today also finalized the preparations
for the European Council that will be
held this week on the ninth and tenth of
March the European Council will be
focusing once again on jobs growth and
competitiveness in particular how to
ensure a sustainable economic growth job
creation and competitiveness across the
Union European Council is expected to
discuss the situation the Western
Balkans it is important that the you
sends the message that it remains
committed to the region and will stay
engaged at all levels regional
cooperation and good neighbor relations
remain essential and fundamental to
ensure and a reversible process process
whereby every single one of the Western
Balkans partners move forward on the
reform path towers European Union